elle a dit c'est à dire que lorsqu'il ya
un prix qui va la maladie c'est la
prédation lorsque ya un prix qui
augmentent c'est parce que vous avez une
demande s'ils explosent avec une offre
web si elle ne ne suit pas la demande
donc traiter la maladie s'est traité la
pénurie dans le rôle de masquer son rôle
malgré tout ça c'est donc traiter la
pénurie c'est donc accroître l'offre
pour que les prix baissent c'est tout
simplement les mécanismes de base de
l'offre et la demande je suis désolé que
dans un monde où l'information assez
importante la paix nous dit que des
mesures fortes sont annoncés par
emmanuel macron ce soir alors à la
demande du président gérard larcher et
le président va se parler par téléphone
ou qu'on ne sait pas très bien de quoi
il va retourner à l'intervention d'
emmanuel macron ce soir notre question
peut-on avoir confiance en notre système
de santé nos attentions partager avec 58
58 % de oui
non plutôt de votre avis alexandre
délicieuse jeu c'est un système qui
était très performant et qui a été
entamée ces dernières années
apparaissent même parfaitement confie qu
confiant jeudi raids dans les personnels
hospitaliers on peut être sûr qu'ils
vont être dévoué et qui feront le avec
qui font le maximum alors emmanuel
macron prépare en ce moment depuis ce
matin l'intervention télévisée qu'il
fera d'ici deux petites heures
maintenant toute la matinée le premier
ministre a reçu de son côté les
présidents des assemblées des groupes
parlementaires les chefs de parti les
présidents des associations d'élus ne
sont semble pas de sortie convaincu
complètement convaincu de ces entretiens
on écoute bruno retailleau il faut que
monsieur macron prennent la tête d'une
coordination européenne il devrait déjà
avoir été a par exemple à berlin comme
ce qu'ils avaient fait il ya dix ans
monsieur sarkozy et il faut aussi une
réunion du g20
il faut une coordination internationale
c'est fondamental et l'impression que
donne la france pour l'instant c'est
plutôt d'être à la remorque alors avec
son mari est ce qu'on est à la remorque
c'est une vraie question je pense qu'on
est dans une approche un peu n'ont pas
suivi ce mais on est on est forcément
réaction chaque jour apporte son lot de
surprises
est ce que la france le plan d'une
initiative très sincèrement dans le
contexte actuel je vois pas quel est le
bon cadre pour arriver à fédérer les
énergies
en revanche évidemment ce soir on
s'attend à ce que vous disiez à ce qu'il
ya des véritables mesures qui soit
annoncé à la fois pour montrer que nous
aussi on a des gros bras et envoyer un
son de signaux ce qui me préoccupe c'est
le signal qu'on enverrait en capacité et
finalement de de doute sur notre
résilience avec les élections de
dimanche je trouve que annoncé le report
des élections c'est une forme de
capitaliser capitulation en rase
campagne ça je trouve que c'est un style
non mais je pense qu'on puisse les
écouter
j'en sais rien j'ai pas tous les
éléments donc c'est très difficile mais
objectivement mais sincèrement je trouve
que le signal envoyé est un signal qui
est comme un signal d'une anxiété
extraordinaire et pour le coup j'ai peur
quand en effet cascade et des signaux
bien géré je pense qu'on peut envoyer
des signaux mais objectivement enfin
partout où les gens vont continuer à
l'ecam s'approvisionnait faire des
achats
parce qu'il va bien falloir survivre
quand même si on entre dans une période
de confinement bien falloir sortir ce
sera aussi dangereux d'aller voter
dimanche que d'aller malgré tout acheter
son pain ou aller au supermarché même au
même moment même en petits groupes
même en petits groupes donc à un moment
donné voilà je suis pas sûr qu'ils
fassent basculer dans l'hystérie et je
pense qu'au contraire faut prendre des
mesures fortes mais en même temps il
faut pas parce que l'autre côté sinon on
va encore amplifier l'effet les autres
phénomènes qui sont des phénomènes
effectivement cataclysmique sur un plan
économique et sur un plan de phénomènes
boursiers etc
et derrière le pire sera sera sera sera
à craindre le sanitaire et l'économique
battant problème de l'intervention de
bono retailleau le tour y ait des choses
qui sont du ressort de notre
souveraineté a noué ce qu'il faut fermer
les frontières à ce qu'il faut prendre
des mesures de confinement plus en plus
drastiques que reporter les élections
etc
ça c'est dur du vieux besoin de
convoquer l'union européenne encore mois
le g20 pour faire ça par contre il ya
des choses qui sont malheureusement plus
du ressort de notre souveraineté si on
veut faire une politique de relance
économique on a vu ça dépend de la
banque centrale sa dépendent
il faut il faut se mettre d'accord et là
à mon avis on peut peut-être anticipé la
crise économique qui vient on a vu
l'effondrement des bosses et c est là
c'est vrai que une réunion volontariste
européenne comme l'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy au moment de la crise
8pour immédiatement relancé comme au
fait les britanniques ou qu'on me l'a
fait donald trump ça me paraît pas idiot
je sais pas si vous êtes dans la phase
de relance mais ils ont gagné ce soir là
de manière manuelle mac os je suis pas
président de la république donc c'est
compliqué qu'est ce que je ferais ce
soir déjà moi je suis je ne sais pas
quelle est la gravité de la chose si ça
va être exponentielle ou pas mais en
tout cas s'il s'exprime j'espère que
c'est pour dire quelque chose ça c'est
c'est c'est que fait qu'il est prêt à
prendre des mesures fortes et c
mais non j'ai pas enjamber le sanitaire
enfin tout tout ce tout se tient donc si
la crise est extrêmement grave
peut-être qu'il faut faire la même chose
que l'italie et ses affaires des des
mesures beaucoup plus forte d'isolement
et c est par contre pour pour ce qui est
du ressort économique moi je pense que
là il faut faut que les européens
agissent vite j'aimerais qu'on aurait
aimé qu'on puisse agir à l'échelle
française mais c'est plus le cas dans
une avec l'euro etc
c'est impossible à faire donc là il faut
effectivement ça me paraît pas absurde
de se réunir et de prendre des mesures
beaucoup plus volontariste qu'on est en
train de les prendre garde qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
moi je pense que c'est là qu'est ce que
c'est une la bonne intervention du
président ce soir je pense que c'est une
intervention était déjà modeste à dire
qu'une intervention qui s'appuie sur les
parties prenantes et s'abstenir de jouer
à l'homme providentiel qui va tout
régler depuis les 10 et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est assez tentant dans un
régime qui est très centralisé très
scénaristes comme le nôtre mais je pense
qu'il faut faire c'est des fois de
modestie s'appuyer sur ceux qui savent
les professions de santé faciliter leur
travail prendre exemple sur les aussi
les pays qui ont qui ont bien géré cette
crise on a parlé de la corée du sud n'a
pas lu de taïwan voir si voir si c'était
dans ces pays là pour avoir les retours
d'expérience non la chine je ne pense
pas que l'on puisse trouver leur compte
prise trop proche de la corée du nord et
les premières semaines de gestion de la
crise de la chine qui a conquis a
consisté à étouffer les voix qui et les
lanceurs d'alerté je ne pense pas que ce
soit un modèle de gouvernance c'est
différent mis sur la gestion de la crise
une fois qu'elle était immergée pardon
l'om s était dithyrambique sur la
gestion de la crise après ces trois
semaines
oui bien sûr mais on n'a pas les moyens
en fait la question se pose pas
tellement besoin on n'a pas les moyens
pour le coup on n'a pas un état en
capacité et dieu soit loué je me suis
oui étatiste mais on n'a pas un état
totalitaire sont celles où on filmait
des pièces qu'on entend par action fort
c'est à dire que cette cette volonté de
l'action ford pose quand même trois
problèmes premier c'est quel est le
niveau du risque acceptable que l'on
s'impose quelle est la contrepartie que
nous sommes prêts d'affaires pour pour
réduire ce risque
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord ici que
réduire pour dire que le réduire le
risque de virus c'est certes un objectif
souhaitable mais pas n'importe quel prix
sinon on assignerait chacun résidence il
voyait bien que on est encore ici on
veut encore bénéficier de la vie sociale
parce qu'on est prêt aussi à à tolérer
un certain niveau de risque
donc attention ne pas donc plus tomber
dans la démagogie lente oui alors cessé
de c'est en fait il n'y a pas de réponse
universelle c'est parce que la version
release ce quelque chose de très
subjectif
la notion de contrepartie acceptable et
là encore quelque chose de subjectif il
ya des gens vous leur dites vous avez
une chance sur deux de crever de faim en
sortant bon bah ils vont continuer à
sortir ils vont continuer à profiter de
la vie et d'autres personnes vous leur
dites vous avez une chance sur un
million de vous faire attaquer par un
terroriste ils vont rester chez eux
confiné parce que ils sont très frileux
donc il n'ya pas de réponse universelle
je pense que c'est aussi quelque chose
qui dépend de facteurs culturels
psychologie quels sont les risques
quelles sont les contreparties que nous
sommes prêts à accepter pour faire face
à ces défis sanitaires ou est-ce qu'il
faut mettre le curseur entre les
sanitaires l'économique le risque tout
est là vous demandiez
la réponse européenne est ce qu'il faut
aller à berlin etc je pense que là on
est on navigue à vue je veux dire j'ai
effectivement en demandant à ceux qui
savent pas ce qu emmanuel macron ne sait
pas donc il se renseigne pour essayer de
comprendre et d'adapter la meilleure
stratégie de défense par rapport à ce
virus qui se propage très vite il ne
sait pas donc navy totalement à vue et
on voit que les informations du matin
sont démenties 2010 sans démenti soir
donc je pense sincèrement qui fait ce
qu'il peut
il fait ce qu'il peut avec ses moyens
avec l'entourage qui l'a et moi je lui
fait plutôt confiance parce que parce
qu'il est président la public et qu'il a
tous les leviers pour faire quelque
chose maintenant c'est quoi une mesures
volontaristes ce soir effectivement il
vaut mieux qu'avant pour qu'on le
regarde nous dise pas je vais rien
annoncé parce que en termes de
sédentaires de communication il guérit
greer est une cartouche fondamentale en
allant pour ne rien dire
peut-être j'en sais rien moi je suis pas
franchement je n'en sais rien ce matin
ce matin c'était une connerie ce midi à
la rumeur a commencé à courir et de ce
soir c'est devenu une évidence
vous avez ce matin vous avez ce matin
gérard larcher qui a reçu par hu man et
le maquereau
vous avez des débuts qui dit la sortie
qu'il va annuler les municipales
larcher et dément et ce soir il a un col
téléphonique avec le président de la
république
franchement je crois qu'on en ait step
by step c'est tellement une dévolution
et en temps réel que étrange quand même
c'est d'annuler les municipales alors
qu'il ya eu la campagne
tout le monde ya vu des meetings et
c'est à ce moment-là fallait les annuler
bien avant là on est à la veille du vote
ça me paraît ça me parait étrange et
incohérent je pense qu'il ya deux noms
dynavie il navigue à vue si vraiment il
navigue à vue encore à l'heure actuelle
c'était pas la peine de parler moi je
pense que c'est ça c'est s'il parle il
faut qu'il ait une stratégie établie et
ensuite que tout soit cohérent si on va
vers des mesures de confinement très
drastiques là il va falloir prendre
aussi des mesures économiques qui vont
avec et c'est théophile ça confirme
quand même qu'en matière de gouvernance
quand on tire à quelques leçons quand on
a des ministres en charge et des
polémistes en charge ils s'occupent de
leurs affaires ils restent aux affaires
alors en clair aller faire campagne au
havre allait faire campagne à paris
allait s'occuper d'autre chose que de ce
don en à l'extrême chargé dans un
système qui est quand même très
concentré je pense que c'est folie on
devrait pas accepter cendres plus
accepter ça ou alors si on veut aller
faire autre chose on sort mais regardez
regardez peut-être que peut-être
qu'effectivement quand agnès buzyn dit
je change mais on change la chaîne de
commandement en pleine période de crise
et un moment donné et stratégique
peut-être qu'effectivement ça nous met
dans la vue les 8-10 jours qui
permettent à vos successeurs pour se
mettre vraiment dans les rails du
problème quoi ça peut être avoir des
conseils on peut le regarder la position
de la france et son meeting ce soir
manière dont on dispose je veux dire
l'information dont dispose aujourd'hui
d'un rien avoir accès d'autres disposer
il ya 24 heures il ya 48 heures et de
traits activités d'autres réactions
notre sensibilité par rapport aux
événements par rapport à la contagion de
la peur et tu radicalement différente de
celle qui avait il ya trois jours donc
façon quand on est promu ministre on est
premiers ce qu'on fait rien d'autre
alors voilà le seul message clair c'est
peut-être celui là les seuls concerts et
que vous donne un président pour ce soir
nous allons attendre pendant deux heures
nous en saurons plus
vous pouvez suivre toute l'actualité sur
le corps d'un virus sur le site du
figaro.fr et sur le figaro merci à tous
et bonne soirée dont nous retrouvons
demain point de vue 17 heures merci et
bonne soirée